[Musik]
ob bier sekt wein oder stärkeres alkohol
gehört für viele zum alltag
trinke alkohol weil man sich einfach gut
fühlt so
doch vom genoss bis zur sucht ist das
nur ein schmaler grat
er war alle drei bis vier tage so viel
getrunken der sich besinnungslos in der
ecke lagen allein in deutschland haben
drei millionen menschen ein
alkoholproblem
doch fast unbemerkt entsteht ein neuer
trend spaß ohne alkohol
[Musik]
noch vor vier jahren beim atelier stüben
gefangen in einem leben das sie nicht
führen wollte
sie trank bis zum umfallen und das über
jahre an kinder wäre nicht zu denken
gewesen
in ihrer not sucht sie rat unerkannt im
internet um sie herum märkte kein mensch
etwas
ich habe zwei tage nichts getrunken drei
tage nichts getrunken und ich merke ja
sogar wie sp den tagen dann besser ging
also zumindest zum zweiten und dritten
tag und dann habe ich aber wieder
getrunken und nach zwei drei gläsern
konnte ich nicht mehr aufhören
ich konnte nicht mehr auf die kleine
familie lebt der bayerischen rosenheim
bald werden sie zu viert sein ich habe
mich immer gefragt warum kann ich nicht
aufhören ich krieg doch alles in meinem
leben warum kann ich nicht aufhören zu
trinken wenn ich anfangen
es hat für mich keinen sinn ergeben ob
abhängig oder nicht der
durchschnittliche alkoholkonsum in
deutschland ist hoch
131 liter alkoholische getränke pro kopf
pro jahr quasi eine ganze badewanne voll
[Musik]
wiesbaden am rhein
die gegend ist für ihren riesling
berühmt war ein gehört hier zum
lebensstil auch für die freunde liane
rené marcel und wolfgang manchmal wird
es zu viel des guten und das schlechte
gewissen plagt denn eigentlich weiß es
ja jeder alkohol schadet dem körper und
das ab dem ersten schluck
mit alkohol werden über 200 krankheiten
in verbindung gebracht
bereits kleine mengen erhöhen das risiko
für schäden am gehirn magen und darm
leber oder herz die wahrscheinlichkeit
von krebserkrankungen und
verkehrsunfällen steigt etwa 74.000
menschen sterben in deutschland jedes
jahr durch riskanten alkoholkonsum
deshalb fassen sie einen entschluss das
letzte gläschen für sieben wochen also
ich zum beispiel trinker am liebsten
sagt oder wein beim ich das eben für
unheimlich aber waren uns zu lassen es
zu welchen anlässen zu anlässen du das
muss kein besonderer anlass sein also
trinke alkohol weil man sich einfach gut
fühlt also wenn ich das trinken welches
marco und alles so also der geschmack
und das feeling
es geht also darum geht vielmehr um
genuss schon und und auch so ein
belohnungsprinzip hatte zb im dezember
festgestellt dass ich ziemlich viel
alkohol getrunken haben auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt ist gefühlen beine sind
weihnachtsfeiern alkohol gehört in
vielen teilen der welt zur kultur eine
droge gesellschaftlich akzeptiert in
deutschland beträgt der statistische
pro-kopf-verbrauch 13,4 liter pro jahr
in reinem alkohol gerechnet damit liegt
deutschland vor den wein liegenden
franzosen und weit vor italien über dem
europäischen durchschnitt
ab morgen wollen die vier freunde fasten
und sich selbst auf die probe stellen
können sie noch ohne alkohol leben
wie schwer wird ihnen der verzicht
fallen sieben wochen sind eine lange
zeit
in rosenheim macht sich natalie stüben
auf den weg nach düsseldorf vier stunden
wird sie unterwegs sein
bei ihrem fernseh-auftritt will sie
erzählen wie sie ihrer alkoholsucht
überwunden hat mit rat und
rückenstärkung von anderen die unter
derselben krankheit litten hilfe die sie
online fand in englischen podcast
ein ziel ist es leute verstehen was für
eine gemeingefährliche droge das ist und
dass leute viel früher bereit sind die
reißleine zu ziehen wenn sie bemerken
ich komme nicht mit zurecht die podcast
dir damals halfen gab es auf deutsch so
nicht deshalb hat sie ihr eigenes
diskussionsforum entwickelt ohne alkohol
mit natalie heißt ihr kanal jede freie
minute arbeitet sie daran
neulich hat sie ein interview mit der
schauspielerin muriel baumeister
aufgenommen
die beinahe an ihrer alkoholsucht
gestorben wäre und dann habe ich
angefangen panikattacken zu kriegen weiß
nicht ob du mal welcher hattest danke
dem schöpfer das fühlt sich so an dass
du nur sterben will das alles mit
körperlichen befindlichkeiten also dass
du wirklich ein herzrasen
schweißausbrüche
du kannst kaum laufen du kannst nicht
atmen muss der ganze körper sagt stopp
wie lange dauert das halbe stunde bis
tun und es hat sich dreimal täglich
ein kalter entzug rettet muriel
baumeister schließlich das leben
neben dem podcast hatte die stuben ein
30 tage programm für alkoholabhängige
entwickelt um ihnen einen weg raus aus
der sucht aufzuzeigen
[Musik]
rundum rüdesheim liegt der eingang
berühmt für seine riesling weine schon
seit der römerzeit gehört wein hier zur
kultur
[Musik]
bernhard jungs weingut liegt mittendrin
ein passendes ausflugsziel für die
fastenzeit die sich die freunde aus
wiesbaden auferlegt haben wein ohne
alkohol täters manche leute sagen ja
alkoholfreien wein oder sekt ist das ein
saft mittlerweile verzichten die freunde
seit über zwei wochen auf alkohol und
lernen dabei sich und ihre gewohnheiten
ganz anders kennen ich war konsequent
ich habe einmal gesund mit einer samba
jona ich hab sie nicht so schnell
gepackt das heißt ich habe noch ein
bisschen weiter getrunken
gewohnheitsmäßig meinen 61 und auch
schon mal am nachmittag und dann hatte
ich aufgehört das war dann schon auch
ein hartes ding also das ging so dass
ich nachts erst mal nicht einschlafen
wollte ja und dann alkohol beruhigt ja
auch irgendwie das nimmt auch ängste
wecken das ist schon toll wenn das gut
lassen kann
emily ist eigentlich sehr gut ich habe
doch gar keine probleme gehabt ich habe
nur ein einziges mal aus wir sehen
alkohol und jubelt bekommen ob riesling
oder merlot in seiner weinbrennerei
verarbeitet jung aroma reiche sorten zur
alkoholfreien weinen doch wie behalten
sie ihren geschmack
wir sind hier beim herz unserer firma
und zwar bei der ente alkoholisierung
sun lage das besondere an der anlage ist
dass sie mit einer aroma rückgewinnung
ausgestattet ist das heißt wir entziehen
dem wein zunächst die aromastoffe die
leicht flüchtig sind die also den wein
gespannt ausmachen dann entziehen wir
den alkohol wer eigentlich farb und
geschmacklos ist und führen dann diese
aromastoffe wieder zu also hier zum
beispiel läuft im moment ein
alkoholfreier aber nie sauvignon unter
hohem vakuum und bei niedrigen
temperaturen wird dem wein der alkohol
entzogen
eine idee von jungs großvater ein
tüftler seiner zeit voraus
rund zehn millionen flaschen seiner
weine verkauft jung pro jahr in 30
verschiedene länder
das weingut hat sich spezialisiert wir
waren jahrelang die einzigen und sind
mittlerweile so dass wir nichts anderes
machen wir machen nicht auch alkoholfrei
sondern wir machen nur alkoholfrei nicht
nur in deutschland in ganz europa wächst
der markt auch italien spanien
frankreich belgien und schweden sind auf
diesen trend aufgesprungen
mit derselben philosophie gute weine
brauchen geschmack aber keinen alkohol 0
prozentiger wahlen ist das eine echte
alternative
die wiesbadener freunde haben eine
weinverkostung gebucht
ich finde es großartig und es geht
wirklich um geschmack und genuss und den
sich das entspricht zu meinem
lebensgefühl wenn ich dann schönes essen
kaufen und dann kann ich mir ja gesund
genießen erst ihre fastenzeit hat die
freunde aus wiesbaden auf die idee
gebracht
noch aber liegen fünf wochen vor ihnen
braucht das ab und an doch ein echtes
gläschen wein schon früh am morgen ist
netter die stuben in düsseldorf
unterwegs ins fernsehstudio
sie ist nur ungern von ihrer familie zu
hause in rosenheim getrennt aber der
auftritt ist ihr wichtig die
journalistin will ganz offen über ihre
frühere alkoholabhängigkeit sprechen
in der hoffnung dass andere nicht
dasselbe durchmachen müssen
hinter den kulissen laufen bereits die
letzten vorbereitungen für die live
sendung kurz vor der sendung lernt
natalie stuben volle kanne moderatorin
nadine krüger kennen und bloggerin raus
ich bin noch keine trockene
alkoholikerin okay diese worte verwende
ich bewusst nicht gut was würdest du
dann verwenden ehemaliger alkoholikerin
die alkoholikerin gar nicht ich war
alkoholabhängig
ok unbedenklich ist alkohol nie wer
trotzdem trinken will dem empfehlen
experten einen massvollen konsum männern
höchstens 24 gramm pro tag das
entspricht etwa einem halben liter bier
oder einem viertel liter wein und das an
maximal fünf tagen pro woche
für frauen gilt gerade einmal halb so
viel
wunderschönen guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zur volle
kanne natalie stevens ziel der sucht das
dickmann nehmen denn auch die
gesellschaft trägt für sie eine
mitschuld wenn der einzelne in die
abhängigkeit rutscht verherrlichen diese
droge ungemein und auf der anderen seite
stigmatisieren wird die die abhängig
sind
und das führt zu einem ganz ganz
schwierigen missverhältnis weil wir auf
der einen seite so tun als könnten wir
alkohol kontrollieren als wäre es total
normal dass zu konsumieren und auf der
anderen seite die verurteilen dies
konsumieren und die dann problem
entwickeln so letzter fernsehauftritt
bei der geburt zu blicken
natalie stuben will den zuschauern mut
machen einmal ehrlich in den spiegel zu
schauen heißt der freunde aus dem umfeld
anderen relativ zügig gesagt okay wir
müssen wir helfen oder anderswo muss der
hilfe suchen oder wie hast du ein ende
gefunden
das habe hat mein umfeld nicht gesagt
das liegt aber auch daran dass so viel
unwissen herrscht was dieses thema
angeht ich habe mein leben ja immer noch
ganz gut auf die kette bekommen ich war
erfolgreich im beruf ich hatte eine
wohnung ich war gepflegt ich habe zwar
an seite benutzt sie all diese die nach
außen hin den anschein erwecken dass
alles okay ist klar ich habe ein
bisschen viel getrunken und ich habe es
immer mal wieder übertrieben aber das
wurde er noch so als emanzipation
eingeordnet so als freiheit die lässt
sich halt nicht sagen denn als problem
was als normal gilt ist oft schon sucht
drei millionen menschen in deutschland
haben ein ernstes alkoholproblem
schätzen experten eindringlichen worte
die wahrheit ist nicht immer schön aber
sie kann ein heilsamer schock sein
die wiesbadener freunde haben es hinter
sich
sieben wochen verzichten doch zur feier
des fastenbrechens können sie wegen
corona nur online anstoßen
doch das ist ja auch immer ein schönes
schöne begleiterscheinung und ich bin
der meinung ich werde es noch eine zeit
lang durchhalten gar nichts zu sein muss
ich zugeben dass ich das fasten schon
vorher gebrochen habe weil er ganz viele
freunde von mir wegen corona fast jeden
tag am saufen jobs alkohol fasten
durchgehalten
ich hab nur wasser und säfte
also eigentlich wasser und säfte
getrunken
wolf rcl dies ist die eltern also ich
bin aber geblieben
schon wenige wochen alkoholverzicht tun
der gesundheit gut
wir schlafen besser unser blutdruck
sinkt das hautbild verbessert sich die
leber regeneriert sich wir haben bessere
laune und mehr energie
[Musik]
ihr fazit dass alkohol fasten war nicht
immer leicht aber eine wertvolle
erfahrung leben ohne alkohol für ein
paar tage die woche ein paar monate im
jahr
das macht einen unterschied für körper
und geist
[Musik]